hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and in this video
i will be explaining the mind-bending
time travel aspect of attack on titan
and how it completely changed everything
we thought we knew about the story up to
this point i've been seeing a lot of
questions and confusion about this
aspect of attack on titan especially
from anime only fans who only just got
fully introduced to it so that is why i
decided to make this video and break it
all down for you in one place if you
guys enjoy our attack on titan content
and you want to see more leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps a lot with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications we have been making
attack on titan content for years we
have an entire playlist dedicated to
attack on titan and we're gonna keep
making more content in the future
finally this video will contain attack
on titan spoilers for the anime but i
will not go into manga spoilers so
please be advised now the chapter
covering this part of the story in the
manga chapter 121 has been out for well
over two years so us manga readers have
been familiar with all this time travel
stuff for a long time we've had time to
think about it and we've had time to see
how it all plays out that said even
manga readers might benefit from a video
that explains everything in one place so
that is why i will be doing right now
okay so let's go back to where it all
went down because zeke wants to show
aaron the truth about his father grisha
he uses the founding titan's power and
the paths to essentially allow zekenron
to walk through many of grisha's
important memories it is crucial to
remember that this is zeke using the
founding titan to allow him and aaron to
travel through these memories this is
not aaron using the founding titan and
also this is not aaron using the attack
titan because the attack titan's power
is not to view other people's memories
aaron and zeke have been traveling
through gracious memories for what feels
like years although time within the
paths is different from the time in the
outside world this means that the time
the two of them spent in grisha's
memories is not necessarily a reflection
of how time is passing on the outside
after moving through these memories for
quite a while zeke finally concludes
that grisha did not try to brainwash
aaron with the ldn restorationist
ideology like he had tried to do to him
back when he was a child grisha
apparently learned his lesson after
losing his first family and he tried his
best to be a better husband and father
to carla and aaron but then zeke wonders
why his brother aaron would betray him
if he wasn't brainwashed by grisha why
wouldn't he just agree to put the
euthanasia plan into motion and save the
world from the titans aaron simply
explains that he and zeke are different
ever since he was born aaron wanted to
be free and if someone tries to take
away his freedom he won't hesitate to
take away theirs first aaron rejects the
marlin propaganda that pushes collective
guilt upon the aldians as a people and
he also rejects the naive idea that
euthanizing aldians would bring about
some sort of world peace and i mean
aaron is absolutely right blaming the
current generation of aldians for what
happened hundreds of years ago is
ridiculous and in our own world we don't
have any titans but war and conflict
still exists so there is absolutely no
guarantee that if all titans disappeared
then war and suffering would suddenly
end despite aaron's response zeke still
believes that the two of them can find
memories which prove that grisha was a
bad person one memory in particular is
extremely interesting to zeke the memory
in which grisha kills the rhys family in
the name of ldn restoration but we'll
talk more about that later first we have
to remember that these trips through
grisha's memories are not actually time
travel this is just supposed to be zeke
and aaron using the founding titan power
to look at what has already happened and
the two of them are not supposed to have
any effect on the events that take place
in these memories they're just supposed
to be invisible and formless spectators
of everything that's going on they're
kind of like ghosts that no one can see
or interact with in any way however
things take a strange turn when grisha
from the past sees zeke the older zeke
from the present standing right in front
of him grisha even confirms that he saw
zeke as a bearded man but because he
only glimpses zeke briefly after just
waking up from a nap grisha assumes that
it was all just a dream zeke is
extremely surprised and confused by this
but aaron doesn't look nearly as shocked
in fact aaron rushes zeke to move on to
the next memory as if he doesn't want
zeke to think too much about what just
happened this tells us that aaron knew
what was going on or at least he was
starting to figure it out and he had a
very specific plan for this little trip
down memory lane when they finally get
to the memory of grisha killing the rhys
family and stealing the founding titan
we see grisha trying to convince frieda
reese the current holder of the founding
titan power to please do something to
protect the innocent people on parodies
from the titans he isn't threatening her
or trying to take the founder by force
he is trying to explain to her with his
words that his own family lives right
next to the walls where the titans are
attacking it really seems like at this
point in his life grisha isn't asking
for ldn restoration and he isn't even
asking for revenge he just wants the
founder to protect the innocent
civilians on the island and by the way
these civilians are the people that the
royal family is directly responsible for
protecting these are their subjects but
frida is unable to do anything due to
the pacifist ideology of king carl fritz
the first king behind the walls even
though she herself looks conflicted the
will of carl fritz takes over her body
and after that she refuses to even
consider interfering in any way she says
that the aldians have committed
unspeakable sins in the past and it is
time for them to pay for those sins even
if all the aldians on the island are
killed it still wouldn't make up for all
of their horrible crimes from the past
grisha tries to explain that the people
who are now alive on the island bear no
responsibility for the sins that their
ancestors committed hundreds of years
ago these people don't even know what
happened before they came to the island
because their memories were wiped by the
founder so they are completely ignorant
of why they're being attacked in the
first place how could it possibly be
fair to allow all of these innocent
people to die in complete ignorance
grisha keeps begging and pleading but
the founder does not budge according to
the will of carl fritz the aldians
cannot atone for the sins of their past
and they deserve everything that's
happening to them as long as ldns are
the only ones who are dying and no one
else is suffering because of them trying
to fight back then that is exactly how
things should be zeke tells aaron that
he agrees with much of what the founder
is saying he also reminds aaron that
grisha is about to slaughter these
people including the children because of
his ruthless ideological commitment to
ld and restoration but aaron aaron is
absolutely furious when he hears the
twisted logic that's coming from freda
he is so furious that both zeke and
grisha notice how angry he is and yeah
since these are just memories grisha
should not be able to see aaron or sense
him in any way this incident happened
like a decade ago and yet grisha does
sense aaron similarly to the way that he
was able to see zeke in the previous
memory when frida says that there is no
point for grisha to even take the
founder because he wouldn't be able to
use it without royal blood grisha
reveals that the attack titan possesses
its own special power the attack titan
and its inheritors have a tendency to
resist the orders of the royal family
and they are known for standing up to
the self-righteousness of the king this
is because the attack titan is always
looking forward looking beyond the past
and present in fact the attack titan has
the unique power of seeing into the
future more specifically the current
holder of the attack titan power can see
the memories of the attack titan's
future inheritors in other words the
current attack titan holder can see
future events through the memories of
its future holders he can see memories
of the future hardly anyone seems to
have even been aware of this power and
the information comes as a surprise to
both zeke and freda presumably the
founding titan should know everything
about the titans including all of their
powers
but maybe frida's ability to use all
that founder knowledge is limited due to
her being trapped by the valve pacifism
perhaps that is why she doesn't know
about this power although there is
another possibility but that's something
i already explored in a future video you
would know that if you've already
received those future memories but if
you don't have future memories of that
video and you'd like to see it once it
actually comes out don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications okay so in
this moment grisha is supposed to
transform into a titan and kill all the
members of the rhys family except for
rod reese zeke is fully expecting grisha
to do this and he is waiting for him to
do it so that aaron can see what a sick
and twisted man their father was but
when it comes down to it grisha backs
down as a doctor someone who is
responsible for saving lives he simply
can't bring himself to end the lives of
innocent people including children so he
drops down to his knees and gives up on
the idea of taking the founder for a
brief moment it seems like the events we
are witnessing in grisha's memories are
not going to turn out the way that we
know they should grisha is supposed to
take out darius family and take the
founder but in the end he didn't do it
he couldn't go through with it and that
is when aaron steps in aaron suddenly
stops acting like a passive observer of
grisha's memories and he begins speaking
to grisha directly that's right aaron
from the present time is somehow
speaking directly to grisha from nearly
a decade in the past and grisha can
somehow hear him aaron then tells grisha
to stand up and do what he knows must be
done he reminds grisha of everything he
and the other aliens in marley had gone
through because of the founder's
pacifism he reminds grisha of his sister
of his comrades in the ldn
restorationists and of his wife dina
aaron emotionally manipulates grisha
into giving in to his rage and desire
for revenge and grisha takes the bait he
becomes a titan he takes out everyone in
the rhys family except for rod and he
steals the founding titan power this
means that grisha was not going to go
through with stealing the founder until
aaron from the future directly
intervened in order to ensure that it
would happen in the end the act of
grisha taking the founder and then
transferring that power to aaron was not
something that grisha had orchestrated
it was actually something that aaron
himself made sure would happen when the
terrible deed is done a distraught
grisha tells zeke that from here on out
everything will go according to aaron's
plan grisha has seen a glimpse into
aaron's memories from even further into
the future and the future that grisha
has seen is absolutely horrifying grisha
begged zeke to try to somehow stop aaron
and all of this tells us that aaron has
some extremely gamer plans that he is
about to set into motion in the near
future after this incident aaron and
zeke find themselves outside of grisha's
memories and back inside the coordinate
aaron actually thanks zeke for taking
him on a tour of grisha's memories
because if he hadn't done that using the
founder then aaron who doesn't have
royal blood would not have been able to
do what he just did four years earlier
when he had touched historia's hand
aaron was able to clearly see many of
grisha's memories in attack on titan it
is not unusual for a titan shifter to
see the memories of a previous shifter
especially if that previous shifter was
directly related to the current shifter
by blood when we couple that with the
fact that aaron possesses the founding
titan it isn't too surprising that after
making direct contact with historia's
royal blood aaron was able to see more
of gracious memories even more clearly
than ever before and on top of grisha's
own memories aaron also saw his future
self within grisha's memories he already
saw this very moment that we just
witnessed with frida and the rhys family
as it happened through grisha's eyes and
he has been waiting for it and planning
for it for the past four years but how
did aaron manage to interfere how was he
able to speak to his father directly and
even influence him in the past i mean
it's one thing for aaron to have
memories of all of this happening but
it's another thing altogether for him to
be able to directly communicate with and
even manipulate his father in the past
did aaron literally travel through time
in order to speak to grisha is aaron
using the founding titan to convey
messages to grisha in the past does
aaron have special ghost powers
well we have to remember that at this
point in the story zeke is the one who
is in control of the founding titan not
aaron this means that the only power
that aaron has at his disposal is the
attack titan power and the attack
titan's special ability is to send the
current user's memories back to the past
aaron interfered in the past only by
sharing his own memories of this
incident with grisha so essentially
while grisha was going through this
event in what was for him the present
time he also at the same time
experienced aaron's memory of aaron and
zeke witnessing the same event within
grisha's memories yes i know this sounds
confusing so let me try to simplify as
grisha is going through the act of
talking to frida he is also seeing the
entire event from aaron's perspective at
the same time and that's because aaron
chose to send those exact memories back
to grisha through the attack titan the
things that aaron and zeke are saying
cannot be heard by anyone other than
grisha and he knows what's being said
only because he has access to aaron's
memories similarly the only reason why
grisha can see zeke as a bearded man in
that moment is because aaron sent him
his own memory of bearded zeke watching
grisha this means that grisha can't
actually see aaron because he's seeing
zeke through aaron's eyes whenever
grisha is seeing future zeke it is
because future aaron is also standing
there and looking at zeke as well that
said grisha does know where exactly
aaron is located at any point in time
because again he's seeing everything
through his own eyes and through aaron's
eyes at the same time in short grisha
can perceive aaron and zeke only because
he can see aaron's point of view as
aaron watched the memory of the exact
same event that grisha is currently
living through grisha is seeing the
event through his own eyes and through
aaron's eyes at the same time but
because grisha is experiencing both
things at once the event as it is
happening and aaron's memories of
watching the event he is able to react
in real time to what zeke and aaron are
doing and saying in the future and as
grisha reacts zeke and aaron see those
reactions as they are watching grisha so
it appears as if they are directly
communicating in real time even though
they are actually nearly a decade apart
the actual event happened nearly a
decade before aaron and zeke decide to
watch grisha's memory of that event and
if you're wondering how aaron was able
to touch grisha's shoulder or how grisha
was able to hug zeke they weren't really
making physical contact it only appeared
that way after all if grisha had hugged
zeke after gaining the founding titan
power then zeke's royal blood would have
activated the founder in that very
moment in reality this was just like two
ghosts hugging each other this was not
real physical contact and yes this does
amount to a predestination paradox also
known as a causality loop if aaron
hadn't sent his memories to grisha
through the attack titan grisha never
would have taken the founding titan from
frieda and given it to aaron and so zeke
and erin never would have been able to
visit grisha's memories in the first
place this is ironic since in a
predestination paradox everything that
happens is destined to happen and cannot
be changed which means that aaron's
actions were never truly free even
though freedom was the single biggest
driving force in his life everything he
did was destined to happen and none of
it could ever be changed or at least
that is the most popular and plausible
interpretation of events a different
interpretation would require getting
into some heavy theoretical speculation
about alternate timelines but that is a
topic for another video subscribe if you
want to see that one big question here
is why would grisha ask zeke to stop
aaron but then still go through with
giving aaron the attack and founding
titan powers we know that aaron was only
selectively sharing his memories with
grisha up to this point he was only
showing grisha what he needed him to see
in order to do exactly what aaron wanted
him to do but after he takes the founder
grisha says that he has seen aaron's
memories from even further into the
future and he says that what aaron is
going to do is absolutely horrible and
has to be stopped and yet after all of
that he still goes through with
transferring the titan powers to aaron
the predestination paradox suggests that
grisha had no way to stop this aaron had
to get the titan powers in order to send
those memories to grisha in the first
place so it was impossible for grisha to
keep the powers from aaron because that
would have created an unresolvable
grandfather paradox maybe grisha tried
to do things differently but the events
that followed led him to the same
inevitable outcome no matter what he
tried maybe he changed his mind about
everything after learning what actually
happened to shiganshina maybe he was
afraid that changing the inevitable
would actually destroy the entire
timeline and everyone in it which would
be even worse than whatever aaron was up
to or maybe grisha was just placing his
faith in the fact that zeke or someone
else could ultimately stop aaron in the
future definitely let me know down in
the comments why you think grisha
decided to still go through with handing
the titan powers over to aaron despite
the fact that he was terrified of what
aaron was planning to do i hope that
this video was useful to you in terms of
explaining all of this time traveling
memories stuff it is not technically
these people traveling through time but
the memories are definitely traveling
through time feel free to let me know
how you feel about this twist down in
the comments below if you're looking for
a video to watch next check out this one
i made recently about all of erin's
different titan forms and powers in
attack on titan from the beginning of
the story until the end the link is in
the description and in the pinned
comment don't forget to like subscribe
and you can also check me out on twitter
and instagram at animeopror i want to
give a quick thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma and kyle salisbury these
guys are absolute mad lads and disciples
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
ingrata algital pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamian water the
toasted cheek corey mcgowan the spike
lonely the car dylan isidore spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummings and che whitley finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivania temple king matthew and
demetrius water if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
oh and if you don't have a patreon
account becoming a youtube channel
member gives you the same perks as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you